so Viktor
what do you been up to that's the bottom
of the Atlantic Ocean and I guess I read
too much jules verne as a young boy and
so for the last four years I've led a
team to design and build what is now the
most advanced and deepest diving
submersible on the planet and I have the
ability to personally pilot it too so
this was us in December of last year for
the first time the bottom of the
Atlantic Ocean
and nobody's seen that before right
that's just you know Wow everybody else
who does that like well I think everyone
has seen all the developments last you
know 10 15 years you have a bunch of
people that have the means to explore
outer space like SpaceX or Blue Origin
of those guys and we're going the other
direction so it's a wonderful era of
private individuals spending their
resources to develop technologies that
can take us to places that have never
been explored before and the oceans of
the world is it's almost a cliche to say
it's 70% of our entire planet and of
that 95% is unexplored so what we're
trying to do with our expedition is to
build and prove out a submersible that
can go to any point on the bottom of the
planet to explore the 60% of this planet
that is still unexplored you need a
pretty cool tool to do that right right
now the tool is the the submarine the
limiting factor it's a state-of-the-art
vessel supported by the support ship the
pressure drop it has a two-person
titanium sphere 90 millimeters thick
that keeps it at one atmosphere and it
has the ability to dive repeatedly down
to the very deepest point of the ocean
that you later do the spacex of ocean
exploration yeah it's kind of this
SpaceX of ocean exploration but I let my
own vehicles you're gonna take Elon or
yeah I could take someone down there so
you don't know if you're listening I'll
give you a ride in mind if you give me a
ride in yours
[Laughter]
so tell us what it's like down there I
mean we're talking about like a place
where the pressure is so intense that
it's like putting an Eiffel Tower on
your toe it's more than that it's about
16,000 psi so the issue is that we have
this titanium sphere that allows us to
go down to these extreme depths and come
up repeatedly that's never been done
before
the Challenger Deep has been dived twice
once in 1916 once in 2012 by James
Cameron and they went down they came
back up and those were experimental
craft this is the first commercially
certified submersible that can go up and
down thousands of times with two people
including a scientist and we're very
proud that we just took down the deepest
diving British citizen in history just
three weeks ago dr. Allen Jamison of
Newcastle University who was down with
us on the Java trench so not too much
kind of freaks you out is what I'm
guessing well it's it's a lot different
to go diving yeah you're claustrophobic
you do not want to be in the submarine
we go down quite a distance in the
missions typically lasts 8 to 9 hours in
a confined space so it's very different
than the career I had previous to this
which was mountain climbing where you're
in large open spaces the wind is
whipping it's very very cold this is the
opposite it's much more technical it's
much more about precision and using the
instruments and troubleshooting anything
that could go wrong but actually if
something really goes wrong in the
submersible you're not going to know it
so you're afraid of leaks is what you're
saying yeah leaks are not good but if
it's a leak that's happening well at
least it's not that bad because if it
was really bad you wouldn't know it
again but you know with firing the
capsule that wouldn't be good either but
no it's actually a very very safe
submersible I like to say I don't trust
a lot of things in life but I do trust
titanium I trust math and I trust finite
element analysis which is how you figure
out whether or not things like this can
survive these extraordinary pressures
and conditions and that sphere is so
perfectly machined right like this is a
truly unique craft that was the real
trick is actually building a titanium
sphere that was accurate to one point
one percent of machining and titanium is
a hard metal to work and a lot of people
haven't been able to figure it out but
we were very fortunate I've been working
with an extraordinary team that was able
to make an almost perfect sphere which
when you're subjecting something to
pressure that's the strongest geometry
you can possibly have so when I'm
actually in the submersible and that
hatch closes I actually feel very
confident that I'm gonna go down and
come back up and that's the thing you
double-check right that the hatch is
there only two rules in diving a
submarine number one is close the hatch
securely number two is go back to rule
number one
all right so Atlantic Ocean
check southern ocean check yeah no one
has ever died the southern ocean before
I know why it's really really Hospital
the weather is awful the word collision
kind of comes to mind but we did that
one yes quiet it's over yeah thank you
yeah it's like you're racing through it
and now the Indian Ocean as as Kelly
mentioned yeah that was three weeks ago
we were fortunate up to for the first
time actually solved the mystery if
someone had asked you three weeks ago
what was the deal what is the deepest
point in the Indian Ocean no one really
knew there are two candidates one off of
Western Australia and one in the Java
Trench we have this wonderful ship with
a brilliant sonar we mapped both of them
we sent Landers down to the bottom and
actually verified it's actually in the
center portion of the Java Trench which
is where no one thought it was in fact
every time we've completed one of our
major dives we have to run off to
Wikipedia and change it because it's
completely wrong so it probably takes
longer to get down there and then the
time you're able to spend down there no
we actually spend up actually quite a
bit of time
I have four days of oxygen supply in the
vessel if I'm down there for four days
something's gone so wrong I'm probably
not going to use it but it's about three
hours down to the deepest part of the
ocean and then we can spend usually
three or four hours and then another
three hours up so you don't really stay
in there for more than 10 or 11 hours so
you can get a little tight all right so
the bottom of the Indian Ocean and so
this is something that no one besides
you has ever seen this is actually
imagery from one of our robotic Landers
on the bottom right you can actually see
a robust ass fish that's what it's
actually called but you can see from the
left a creature that's never been seen
before it's actually a bottom glowing
jellyfish called a sucked ass ideon and
no none of them have ever looked like
this before and actually has a small
child on the bottom of its stalk and it
just drifted across beautifully so every
single dive we have gone on even though
we're only down there for a couple of
hours we have found three or four new
species because these are places that
have been isolated for billions of years
and no human being has ever been down
there to film them or take samples and
so this is extraordinary case so what we
were hoping the main objective of our
mission is to build this tool this tool
is a door because with this tool we'll
be able to make more of them potentially
and take scientists down to do thousands
of dives to open that door to
exploration and find things that we had
no idea even existed and so more people
have been to space than the bottom of
the ocean you're one of three you're
gonna up that number you're gonna give
it away
yeah three people have died to the
bottom of the Pacific Ocean the USS
Trieste in 1960 with two individuals
James Cameron in 2012 of his deep-sea
Challenger thank you Jim great sub and
this is the third generation technology
we're not only going to try and go down
actually in two weeks but we're gonna
try and do it in multiple times which
has never been done before if we can do
that we will have proved the technology
and that door will not just go open
it'll stay open
fantastic good luck thank you very much
thank you thank you all
[Applause]
[Music]